Monsieur, vous ne m'aviez pas prévenu
pour le tournage.
On devait se voir tous les deux.
On avait rendez-vous, mais…
Pas le temps ! Ça tourne, là ?
Mais lisez ça au moins.
Pas le temps, j'ai dit.
Bonjour !
Je suis Jean-Daniel YouTube,
le patron de YouTube.
Ça fait des années qu'on ne s'est
pas vu, n'est-ce pas ?
Il se trouve que la plateforme
comporte plein de nouveautés.
Je vous les présente, suivez-moi.
Alors non, cette
partie-là n'est plus accessible.
Ah, des agrandissements ?
J'aime l'idée.
Suivez-moi.
YouTube est un puit sans fond
de connaissances.
Je mets un point d'honneur
à encourager les contenus informatifs.
- J'adore cette créatrice.
- Je vais vous raconter une histoire
qui se passe au tout début
de la seconde mondiale.
Les annonceurs vont pas aimer ça.
Mais il n'y a pas un seul mot sensible.
Si, vous allez parler du mot interdit là.
Ah non, je ne dis pas un seul mot
sur les nazis.
Perdu ! Vous avez dit le mot.
Elle l'a bien cherché.
Il faut que je vous parle absolument
d'une nouvelle catégorie de vidéos
qui cartonne sur notre plateforme.
Je parle bien évidemment de l'ASMR.
Aujourd'hui, on va se détendre ensemble.
C'est vrai que c'est agréable.
J'aime bien.
Plus jamais je rentre dedans.
D'ailleurs, il faut que je vous parle
Bonjour, je suis Nicolas Sarkozy.
Oh non ! Une pub.
J'ai le grand plaisir
de vous lire le Temps des Tempêtes.
Ça, ce ne serait jamais arrivé
avec YouTube Premium.
On y va.
Tu ne comprends rien à la bourse
mais tu veux gagner
Oh non, une deuxième pub, putain...
Tu peux souscrire à
ma formation « special trading »
Aïe... Deux pubs...
- Profites-en !
- Pas de chance.
Avec YouTube Premium,
profitez de vos créateurs préférés
sans aucune publicité.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez remarqué,
mais il y a plein de vieux sur Facebook.
C'est vrai qu'il n'y a pas de pub,
c'est pas mal.
Cette vidéo a pu être
possible grâce à NordVPN.
Grâce à NordVPN, vous
pouvez protéger vos données,
mais aussi changer votre localisation
pour accéder à d'autres contenus
sur des plateformes vidéos.
- J'hallucine...
- Pendant une période très limitée,
vous pouvez profiter
d'un abonnement de deux ans
à prix réduit
en vous rendant sur NordVPN.com/Cyprien.
Cliquez sur le lien dans la description.
Profitez-en, c'est sans risque.
Grâce à la garantie de remboursement,
pendant 30 jours.
Mais vous êtes de mèche, en fait.
Peut-être.
Une de mes grandes fiertés chez YouTube,
ce sont les co…
- C'est quoi ça ?
- On ne peut plus y aller, monsieur.
J'espère que ça va être bien.
Maintenant, il faut
que je vous parle du jeu vidéo.
Ah non, le « gaming »...
Le gaming, c'est l'ADN même de YouTube.
- Ils sont où ?
- Voilà justement.
Je vous disais, il n'y a
plus grand monde ici.
Ah, voilà un « gamer ».
Ah non. Moi, je reste pas du tout.
Je dépose mes VOD
et je retourne sur Twitch.
- Je repars.
- Déjà ?
Non ! Faites un petit « let's play ».
Non, j'ai un train de la hype
qui m'attend.
Je suis désolé. Si tu as « prime »,
n'hésite pas à t'abonner, merci.
Mettez-lui un bon gros pouce rouge
à ce petit con.
Mais il n'y a plus les pouces rouges
vous avez demandé à les enlever.
Fais chier !
Ça me fait penser que dans notre entre…
Vous ne pouvez pas aller par là, monsieur.
Là non plus.
Vous ne pouvez pas aller par là non plus.
Putain, mais c'est ma boîte quand même.
Je peux faire ce que je veux, non ?
Vous faites chier, hein !
- Puisque c'est comme ça.
- Attendez !
Mais monsieur, vous ne pouvez pas passer.
Si, ne me faites pas chier, OK !
Jean-Daniel !
Hé, mais je vous connais, vous !
YouTube, c'est ça ?
Je vous regardais quand j'étais petit.
Oh, la dinguerie !
On est où là, c'est quoi ce bordel ?
On est chez TikTok, monsieur.
Ils ont racheté l'immeuble.
TikTok, mais n'importe quoi.
J'ai jamais validé ça.
Vous me pliez les bagages, n'importe quoi !
Non, monsieur.
Sabine, faites ce que je dis.
Vanessa.
Mon nom, c'est Vanessa !
Et c'est le dernier jour
où on travaille ensemble.
Ça fait des semaines
que j'essaye de vous donner ma démission.
À chaque fois que je viens vous parler,
vous m'envoyez balader comme une merde !
Je suis désolée, je ne voulais pas
en arriver là.
Mais là, je n'ai plus le choix.
- Vous partez ?
- Vanessa !
Quel plaisir de vous voir.
Je croyais que vous commenciez demain.
Le patron de TikTok, mon nouvel employeur.
Enchanté.
Je vous ai déjà vu !
Jean-Daniel, c'est ça ?
On s'est déjà rencontré, oui.
J'ai utilisé une musique de Rihanna
plus de trois secondes dans ma vidéo
et elle a été supprimée.
Un, deux, trois.
Plus jamais tu n'utilises une musique
dont tu n'as pas les droits !
Vous savez chez TikTok,
on a sans arrêt des nouveaux talents,
des nouvelles tendances.
Un tout nouvel algorithme aussi,
c'est incroyable.
Je vais vous faire visiter, venez.
Juste après moi.
- Salut, patron.
- Salut Arvi.
On est sur toutes les nouvelles tendances.
Bien, moi aussi.
Regarde-moi ça,
qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
Ouais pas mal, attends !
Essaye ça.
Oh, cool !
Comment ils ont fait ?
C'est la magie de TikTok, Jean-Da.
Monsieur TikTok !
Plus jamais tu fais ça, toi.
Il ne faut pas l'énerver.
Bon maintenant, on va par là.
Non, par là.
La musique fait partie intégrante de TikTok.
Oui, mais aussi sur YouTube,
j'ai tous les clips,
les musiques à la mode.
Oui, mais nous, on peut les réutiliser.
Pourquoi il pointe des mots comme ça ?
Jean-Daniel, gros boomer.
On s'exprime comme ça sur TikTok.
Oh, le pauvre.
Oui, mais au final,
moi j'aime bien quand ils ferment leur gueule.
Non, attention la barre bleue.
Non parce qu'il y en a qui sont restés
bloqués comme ça,
ce n'est pas beau à voir.
Sept milliards deux cents cinquante mille...
Hé, petit curieux.
Vous gagnez pas mal d'argent.
Oui.
Ce mois-ci, on a fait
50 millions de vues.
Ouais, c'est beaucoup.
50.
C'est bien.
Faut qu'on soit payés quand même.
Ah oui, votre argent, mais oui bien sûr.
Je ne vous oublie pas, les gars.
Hop, deux euros.
Vous partagez, vous vous démerdez.
Puis nous, on garde tout.
Pas con, hein !
Il faut que je vous montre
les « challenge », c'est un carton.
Les filtres aussi, ils sont incroyables.
Je vais vous présenter Bella Poarch aussi
et Charli D'Amelio.
Non, mais c'est bon, j'en ai assez vu.
Vous faites du super travail.
Je ne vous embête pas plus longtemps.
Attendez, vous partez déjà ?
Oui.
Vous allez vous y plaire ici.
Il y a plein de nouveaux contenus,
des nouveaux créateurs,
des gens à la mode,
pas comme moi.
C'est important d'évoluer, c'est bien.
Je vous souhaite une bonne continuation,
Vanessa.
Ne perdez pas votre temps avec moi.
Je me souviens de
mon premier jour chez YouTube,
comment j'étais trop contente.
C'était le plus beau jour
de ma vie, je crois.
Franchement, je pense
que si vous n'aviez pas créé cette plateforme
TikTok, Twitch, tout ça,
ça n'existerait pas.
Ça fait 15 ans que ça existe.
15 ans, c'est énorme.
Ça me paraît tellement loin.
Vous vous souvenez pourquoi à l'époque,
vous vouliez créer YouTube ?
Bien sûr.
Je voulais rapprocher les gens.
Je voulais que n'importe qui,
de n'importe où, de n'importe
quel milieu social
puisse partager une vidéo
et la montrer à ses amis,
à sa famille, des inconnus.
Je voulais casser les barrières.
Vous pensez vraiment tout
ce que vous dites ?
Je suis utopiste, c'est ça ?
Vous savez quoi,
là je pense que vous allez
avoir besoin de quelqu'un
pour vous aider dans votre tâche.
Alors je vous suis, je suis avec vous.
Je reste avec vous, vous
pouvez compter sur moi.
Je vous dirai…
Les « Shorts » !
Quoi ?
On va créer les Shorts.
C'est comme TikTok,
mais en pareil !
On va bien le niquer.
De quoi, des shorts de quoi ?
Allez, Sabine.
On va le niquer !
Des shorts en jean ?
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
et merci NordVPN de l'avoir sponsorisé.
Je vous rappelle que vous pouvez profiter
de l'offre actuelle
en allant sur NordVPN.com/Cyprien.
Vous avez 30 jours de période d'essai.
Ainsi, vous pourrez changer de localisation
pour accéder par exemple
à la Formule 1 gratuite en Belgique
ou à Netflix US.
Merci NordVPN.
Vous soutenez des créateurs comme nous
et ça, ça fait très plaisir.
Je vous dis à très vite
dans une prochaine vidéo.
❤️ par SousTitreur.com